- Hi, I'm looking for a patient
named Rachel Kline.
She's here and dying.
- Okay, that's not how we
talk out loud in a hospital.
Are you family
or celebrity?
- Oh, um, celebrity?
- Okay, we're actually already
checking on that name for P!nk,
so you can go ahead and have
a seat next to her assistant.
- Which one is her--
I found her.
- Wow, you look
exactly like P!nk.
- It's like dogs
and their owners.
This was me
when I first started.
- Whoa, when is that?
- Four weeks ago.
You don't look
like anyone famous.
Did you just start?
- Oh, today's
my first day, actually.
- Well, let me give you
some advice.
Never let your boss
get into aerial gymnastics.
- Oh, don't worry.
I'm not gonna be
an assistant for long.
It's not like a career
or anything.
- Your loss.
P!nk's first assistant is now
the CEO of her apparel company.
- Whoa, really?
- I mean, it's just leotards
for aerial gymnastics,
but she's rich.
- Sorry, ladies,
there's no patient here
by the name of Rachel Kline.
- What?
- Oh, I want to talk
career with you.
Okay, do you know
who Meryl Streep is?
- Yes.
- I don't. I don't.
Because she's old,
and old is bad.
Okay, young is good.
Do you know how many views
your video has?
15 million!
- It does?
- Yeah.
And that means I can make you
the most famous person
in the world...
For the next 14 hours.
- Well, you know, uh,
I think I'm looking for
a little bit more
longevity than that.
I guess I just want, like, a--
you know, maybe a small part
in a miniseries, or, you know,
a role in a director's...
- [snoring]
- Hello?
- Hey, Shuli, it's Cary.
Listen, I changed my mind.
I'm actually gonna need
that video to come down.
- No can do, Care.
Tomi Lahren just called it
an affront to family values.
The gays are back on board.
[all cheering]
- [sighs]
- Wait, I'm sorry.
Why isn't there
a Rachel Kline here?
- This happens
all the time.
It's a dude, some middle-aged
perv who wants attention.
- Ew, but then why would he
pretend to be in a hospital?
- They don't think anyone
will actually show.
They just hope you
feel bad enough
to send a bunch
of free crap to their house
probably so they can
jack off into it.
- Ugh.
- Check the return address.
- It says New Jersey.
- Exactly,
where the pervs live.
- Okay, but if this
keeps happening,
why do you
keep showing up?
- Because one time out of ten
it really is a dying girl,
and if you don't show up,
it's bad optics.
And P!nk doesn't
do bad optics.
She does near constant
aerial gymnastics.
- Well, I'm gonna
go to New Jersey
and I'm gonna confront
this sick perv.
You want to come?
- No, I have to find
some other dying kid
to take a photo with.
- Oh.
- ♪ Haters may hate
but I love how he's gay ♪
- Hey, are you from
that music video?
- Oh, um, yes,
but I'd love to do
a miniseries one day,
like a "Fargo"
or something.
- Oh, that's cool.
Um, I just wanted to say
I came out to my mom today
sort of because
of that video.
- Oh.
- I was scared,
but it actually wasn't as bad
as I thought it was gonna be.
So I guess this is weird,
but, um, thanks?
- That's--wow, that's--
that's nice.
Can I, um--can I give you
a hug or something?
- Sure.
Okay, see ya.
- Bye.
- And good luck
with your miniseries.
- Thanks.
[cell phone buzzes]
- Shuli.
- Hey, Shuli,
I guess you
could leave the video up.
Uh, I'm okay with it now.
- Too bad, Care.
It's coming down.
The A.V. Club just said
it's "no 'Moonlight.'"
- Was it supposed to be?
- It doesn't matter, Cary!
They said it,
and now we're [bleep]ed.
[knocks on door]
- [scoffs]
- He--hello.
- Just what I thought,
a pervert.
- Excuse me?
- You think you
are so smart,
pretending to be
a dying girl so what?
A teen will send you a T-shirt
and you can nut in it?
Well, here's your
little tee, perv.
Nut away.
Oh, yeah, you should cry.
Oh, good, all your little
pervert friends are crying too.
And they're all in black.
- [sobbing]
So Rachel wasn't
at the...because she...
- [sobs]
- I am so sorry
for your loss.
- Yo, what up, roomie?
- Hey, you, um--
you smell good.
- Got to,
going out with Abby tonight.
Don't want my junk to stink
if she's gonna be
down there, you know?
- Totally.
Your, uh--your dick
looks good.
- Thanks.
So does yours.
- What?
Oh, stupid pants.
- ♪ Ah, my young boys
in the truth ♪
- ♪ True, true, true ♪
- ♪ Truth ♪
♪ When you see a real one you
better salute ♪
- ♪ Young boys in the truth ♪
- ♪ True, true, true ♪
- ♪ Truth ♪
♪ When you see a real one,
you better salute ♪
- ♪ Lute, lute, lute ♪
- ♪ Lute, lute ♪
♪ Young boys in the truth ♪
- Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Stop, stop.
- What's up, dude?
Am I doing it wrong?
- No, no, no, no.
That was--
That was great, um.
I mean, it was a little dry.
It was kind of like
a turtle eating a carrot.
But that's not, uh--
that's not the problem.
I can't do this anymore.
- Oh, okay.
- 'Cause every time we do this,
it's great or whatever,
but I just feel
like shit after.
- Oh, no.
You do? Why?
- Because you don't
actually like me.
And that makes me
feel pathetic, okay?
And I'm not pathetic.
I'm a gay icon.
- Whoa, hey, that's cool.
- Yeah.
- Since when?
- This morning.
Yeah.